how's it going rats - today we're going
to finish the pants on the quiz - I'm
surprised we managed to finish the first
one I honestly I can't even believe we
went through that [ __ ] let me just get
back to where we were
I'm gonna remember oh yeah really
Oh
seven minutes seven minutes took me
seven minutes to accomplish absolutely
[ __ ] nothing
oh oh god damn it oh this is never gonna
work
why I have the key
why ha ha Eddie jam yeah I'm never gonna
be able to do this now so 5:30 hand back
that I don't even hit the ball I have
the key but now where the [ __ ] do I go
with it
if I go down I'm so [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] I got damn it oh god what I
do I'm cheating 82-75 what what did a
lot of progress here in one hour
[ __ ] this one would you like a [ __ ]
point now these not gonna give us one
anyway it's either elbow or it's check
points are for the weak and mentally
challenged I'm gonna go the mentally
challenged oh thank you god damn it
go away Bob what I can't click him
please feet thumbs are a bit but let
what why why what do you want from me I
said I got the bomb but killer to kill
the babe we had back I'm not gonna do
that one to declare their fate of Chris
is in your hands
damn it Chris damn it why do I do with
you Chris what do you want from me trace
tell me anything anything please you
sick son of a [ __ ] Oh God Chris what
happened
what is insanely great no yeah I would
say Oh x / strawberry diarrhea this what
diary
since when is theory about the odd right
answer milan violence Oh [ __ ] oh thank
you mister dragon click yes to exit no
how many cats do you have to punch a cat
in the face until it loses oh god I
don't know remember it must have been
between 11 and 14 I do quite frankly
believe it was you do 12 [ __ ] in the
face if you have 40 pounds one hand and
20 pounds in the other what have you got
which of the following are you most
likely to see in America lad no not
lattice cuz this game makes fun of
stereotypes could be a gun but I think
the fact look oh god oh god what - I
think I'm doing something here yeah
dragon here how do you dragon how is
dragon no verb can somebody explain that
jaggon here fees dragged on here no no I
asked them to kick back oh gotta do it
again huh that's ok I don't mind a
challenge
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay don't [ __ ] it I think now pets
dragged on
hahahahahaha where's the best place to
look for blue pissed the internet well
this is gotta be a corpse click the ends
answer an answer it's a type of bird and
I'm a doc and I didn't even know that
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] alright so this year if
you thought for long enough the answer
is obvious I don't need a god to back
this thing why do you gotta know that
and we are back on this little
[ __ ] from hell
ok we got [ __ ] cheating is not cheating
if you [ __ ] a cheese why did that work I
got the key alright we got the key and
the miles for some reason god damn I'm
smidge uh-huh okay I don't understand
this piece of [ __ ] I don't know why
sometimes when I right-click on the
[ __ ] okay but no no it's this way I
can't believe I did
you know what if you think long enough
the answer is obvious yes oh god go away
I'm not gonna use you this time I can
click here I have you here oh yeah that
one
oh god no why do you test me
you have played first oh yeah I played
first Chris I sell o drummer how am i
sposta now what do you want from me
never really which letter come okay [ __ ]
you okay which this that one chance
which letter comes after the t if there
are you hit it here oh I know I know I
know I know
haha oh god oh god Karen Karen I'm gonna
go back and look the footage I don't
[ __ ] know an English man an Irishman
and Scots man wanting to evolve and
order some drinks I'd have thought that
at least one of them would have ducked
so you're a pawn to question 90 of the
impossible quest not bad do you know how
many questions is critize no I don't
because I don't not as I'm typing this
away it's the 16th of August so I'm
speaking to you playing this quiz in the
future amazing so anyone here tell you
once upon a time there was a small spat
member named Steven hi Steven see when
all I wanted to be famous is nominate
someone de niro de Melo the end god I'm
bored I can't believe you got this far
Oh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] dude that is your
[ __ ] story back we gotta finish this
[ __ ] I say that but I have no [ __ ]
idea this one I have Co yeah there was
an arrow in there
I didn't [ __ ] this one holy [ __ ] I'm
a genius
oh okay that one too long day to be
[ __ ]
what am I supposed to do
how many lives do you have none I am on
question 92 of impossible Kristin you
have one life ain't no kittycat [ __ ] I
have one legs oh I get it I don't have a
life right click the odd one out
skip that [ __ ] in the last second what
breaks when you say it when you say
pineapple it doesn't break when I say
sonics neck it doesn't I'm not sanic
when I say silence I break that [ __ ] oh
God
going yeah oh it's ascending again you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I hated this one from the other one I
absolutely [ __ ] hate this one I have
one [ __ ] life we got fifteen point
one that one is first
[ __ ] back again this one is [ __ ]
[ __ ] my my babies watch it click the
smallest what found this Center of what
how many times have you have limors been
mentioned in this quiz Oh God
one fine oh hi I'm good
what am I supposed to do someone explain
to me that point am I suppose that I'm
supposed to pop those [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
this is question 99 oh I'm gonna pop
them
[Music]
turn off the UI god damn it here son I
die oh yeah oh god 8225 82-75 oh it's
Chris Chris your bike crit hi it's time
for [ __ ] you Chris bugger off when the
Chris says type a b c d e f g h i j f
but maybe to be 58
[Music]
why do you distract me from Christ and
run in Swedish this I'm obviously happy
okay Ruby
X is Santa I did it I got a first one is
easy at me
[Music]
all right we're here once again alphabet
got it cut it ABCDEF
the LMNOP qrs tuv express see you in the
next one where we're gonna breakfast
[Music]